[Musique]
tian bonjour vous arrivez bien je viens
juste de finir d'apprendre les leçons
qu'est ce que j'apprends la chimie je
suis encore étudiant
je veux devenir professeur mais en
attendant pour gagner de quoi vivre
je vends des ballons quand le score est
ouvert et je garde les enfants pour la
récréation pour qui l'accident
et là claude puel va faire comme métier
vulcanologue au chimiste
c'est bien c'est anne qu'est ce tu
ferais comme métier plus tard trois
coiffeuses asean aussi un des deux
satellites
c'est de faire que métier plus tard dix
mois infirmière et toi tu rubrique
professeur de mathématiques du baume en
plaindre les mathématiques tiens voilà
sabrina tu l'as bien sabrina qu'est-ce
que là tu as mal à la gorge
tout ce qu'on était en train de faire on
était en train de parler des métiers
qu'on ferait plus tard toi si tu devais
changer de métier il devait laisser ton
kiosque
qu'est-ce que du frais animer son métier
regardez bien ce qu'elle fait
regardez bien ne dit rien et vous serrez
bien côté de moi et vous si voilà c'est
terminé sabrina bon voyons carroll
dr c'est presque ça hein j'ai pas moi
frédéric c'est presque doctoresse rivasi
infirmières c'est ça c'est ça mais c'est
un très beau métier qui va nous mîmes
est un métier là un homme tient pas tu
veux toi carole va bien tu te mets
devant la sabrina si toi à côté de moi
tiens françoise maitret sur les genoux
sabrina allez viens un peu plus près
alors on ne dit rien tu ne dis rien du
mime hockey à l'exil car à la wii
continue
regardez bien fait très attention à ce
qu'elle fait
c'est fini c'est pas fini moi je crois
savoir tout un numéro qu'il nous fallait
des familles en tout cas c'est fini
ah ben tiens hier soir qui a trouvé là
qu'est ce que ça vous dit
boucherie boucher alors le boucher
coughlin viande c'était ça est ce qu'un
ado qu'elle ait trouvé le nom bon allez
claude des nominés tier 1 ce que tu m'as
dit tout à l'heure si deux one ou au
train qui va obliger rythme est là et on
regarde où et françoise qu'avec nous
françoise viens les partis manger les
bandes du kiosque allez vas-y claude
chercher un beau si on dit rien on dit
rien frédéric m tu cherches
et puis après lui donnera sa réponse
d'accord
ça c'est du moulin quel silence tu vois
derrière les stones toutes les
silhouettes
voilà qui revient dans de vente voilà
bon c'est fini
alors qui a trouvé leur donne des
réponses chimiste est ce que c'est ça
c'est ça c'est chimiste on en fait
encore un autre tu veux pas tu veux ou
tu veux pas tu dis oui ninon l'un c'est
pardon françoise qui veut frédéric allez
vas-y tu prends la place tien est un peu
plus près de nous tout le monde voit le
clos de regarde voilà un jeu produit
trouvé voyez un peu ce qu'elle fait 1-1
mais non on dit rien on dit rien dire
après à la fin mais j'ai trouvé ça trop
bien ou mal réglé cette hausse trouve
une petite rue urbain claude patois est
un métier de cheminot
enfin on peut rire rire il aussi des
hommes qu'il faut effectivement c'est
fini bon ben je crois tout le monde a
trouvé un à les toits couturière c'est
saint frédéric
1 c'est un couturier effectivement et
vous pouvez le couturier aussi on en
fait un autre personne moi aussi je vais
aimer montrer le métier que j'aimerais
faire regarder on dit rien dit rien on
regarde le mime de kazimiya mais mais
mais casini non mais c'est un métier du
fait là ouais et alors selon ben
continue contre avons encore un petit
peu en même temps regarde bien ce qu'ils
faisaient
voilà carroll
[Musique]
voilà encore bien ce qu'ils faisaient
sculpteur est ce que ces sculpteurs
voilà c'est aussi parce qu'ils ont peur
alors françoise danseur est ce que c'est
ça tu veux de danseurs quasi mouais avec
le physique que tu as un bon choix c'est
pas sérieux casimir et on sera tous à
l'opéra et à l'opéra casimir